is what you said you said what's so
special about me most women aren't
special
[Music]
well no I'm like seriously what what do
women bring in 2022 that is special
nothing do most women have a cookbook
or do most women really know how to
cater to a man no are most women virgins
on their wedding day no so what what do
most women bring in 2022 that is special
but why is it all about what we can
offer why is it always because
because because
when when you're talking when you're
trying to sell a car if you're trying to
get married right then please I'm not
saying that women are cars it's just an
analogy
but but if you're trying to sell a car
you have to study the buyer and figure
out what the buyers want and that's what
men want
it all became like a competition between
men and women between everyone and
because like oh I need to show off that
I know how to do this and I need to show
off ha I need I can do that but better
you know you don't think that if you're
trying to get married you should
demonstrate that you have wife skills of
course yeah like who has them at the end
of the day not everyone not many women
in 2022 no but you know what though have
you ever read the book uh why do men
love me oh yeah that was written by a
single author that is
that book is on my bedside table that
was my Bible a few years ago like right
next to her astrology set
you have been misled my dear but you
said you've never been in a relationship
so it doesn't work no that's I've been
in it that was me I've been in there I
thought that was no it was pretty teeth
I've been in a relationship but like nah
like if you're not showing me how you
can protect me and how you can provide
for me I'm not cooking you a meal get
lost on a takeaway no why would but why
would you be with that guy in the first
place
welfare's but
but you know like for example to one of
my exes once I and he's um it was like a
slightly recent relationship and um I
was like you know I prepared like his
favorite dishes because I know how to
cook because unfortunately my
grandmother taught me how to do it how
do you say unfortunately because then
like yeah no I know for my friends is
good but like for then someone else
who's not appreciating it like what is
it gonna be good why are you picking
guys that don't appreciate it because
then I found out like later on that he
wasn't really appreciating it like and
and you know like I found out that he
cheated on me and like because I got
messages everywhere of people telling me
because like you know seems like
sometimes people has to come to you and
tell you what and where like he's
probably making mistakes pause for a
second how did he not appreciate it no
he did because like he was like oh my
God this is one of my favorite dishes
that you can make and I was like all
right so that didn't tell me like what
have you done today and he lied and I
was like so why would you lie to me when
you asking me to be honest to you and
I'm like because you can't handle the
truth I can trust me I have I've been
learning so many things and he thought
in his head that I wasn't enough strong
enough to handle that fear but you left
him because of that issue yeah because
like so you weren't strong enough to
handle that issue because like you know
what like um yeah um I call but
why would she stay women make up reasons
they leave men when they when they're
out of love with them
so if you're really in love with him you
wouldn't have left them
um well yeah but like you know by the
way cooking's overrated men don't care
about that anymore no I'm not no I'm
gonna talk I have ubereats
but I'll tell you I don't think it's
like people act like it's like some
special thing yeah I think it's it's
like an it's like a normal thing that
would endure you to a man right yeah
like for example if I cook you a meal
you owe me a relationship now you owe me
like for example like that's like a nice
thing to do for someone right whatever
you know what they say I love you but I
love myself more so that's why I leave
yeah and because
um you know and I had meat and I admit
I'm still in love with that man he's the
love of my life but like but you left
him yeah I love myself no because I love
my I love myself more did you leave
because he cheated
would you say would you say that's
selfish if valuing him
wouldn't you say that's selfish to love
yourself more no because like you you
need you know like everyone says like
you need to love yourself before you
love someone else everyone doesn't say
that women say that I don't know yeah
single single women say that until that
you need to love yourself before a
relationship but if you want to start a
family what do you have to love more of
the family your kids yeah yeah you're
right the family the kids and so it's
like if you're already just
demonstrating before you're even with a
guy that you need to love yourself more
than the relationship then it's like
because like selfish you know because
your kids are going to be forever if
you're in love with him yeah you should
call him on the show live I'm just
trying to get around the idea that you
said you you love this guy and he didn't
tell you something he was dishonest to
you but you could handle the truth but
you you fell out over this issue even
though you know you've just shown that
he should have lied to you yeah but like
if you admit something I can deal with
that but if you're telling me no I've
been doing this instead of that and then
I know what you've done like surely now
is when you actually build the trust by
showing you can handle the truth right
saying hey you don't need to lie to me
anymore we can this is where you get to
negotiate and compromise
right
I mean I don't lie for example if
valuing yourself meant like no if
valuing them meant disrespecting
yourself would you still carry on doing
it do you think that's what it is
because we live in a world full of girls
that put their ass and titties on the
internet every day I am the first one if
I'm valuing yeah yeah so what you're
saying is absolute you weren't
in love with that man you value yourself
you're a sex worker let's call it
straight no but like I I love you myself
I Leave You for Cheating you're asexual
I will admit I stopped doing it while I
was with him because he asked YouTuber
and I tried too but then I went back to
it because because I can't get enough of
it and I don't mean it to disrespect you
but when I you can't get enough of it oh
yeah no does it work yeah in a
professional sense or like yeah it's
fulfilling literally yeah
you need to get back with this guy
that guy really changed another another
strand of this though is is what is
perhaps what Justin often talks about
which is that um if he was genuinely
high value he would have been upfront
with you at the beginning because you're
saying that he lied about it or he he
concealed it whereas actually if he'd
have said up front listen you know
you're my main girl but
guess what yeah that would have been
perfect from my point of view I would be
I was like you know if you were telling
me from the beginning like oh look I
want to do this yeah but and not use my
job against me I could have thought
about it because otherwise it wouldn't
even mean like and you know what like we
can be polyamorous everyone is doing it
let's try
I think maybe that's what we need to
start respecting a little bit more as
opposed to loyalty it's just the honesty
the honesty yeah it's just you know
because I don't yeah and I don't like to
have someone else to comment okay look
at yourself but here's the truth though
because if a man came to you and you
truly loved him and he set you down got
everything out the way and you were
needed me and he looked you dead in the
eyes and said listen I really care about
you obviously I'm gonna see other women
there's no way I'll ever have feelings
for them I want to take care of you
completely I want to be the man that
makes your dreams come true let's go to
the dark side of the moon no I'm gonna
be the rock that your emotional ways
crash into I am there for you I am in
love with you let's have kids I'm gonna
have sex with women every now and then
she that girl's delusional she doesn't
know
and and he tells you the truth instead
of being a coward see the problem is you
don't like a man that's going to be a
coward and lie behind your back because
he's too much of a to tell you the
truth you know the truth you know the
truth I'm gonna jump that every man
wants to do it it's the respect of
sitting you down and telling you the
truth furthermore most often when a
woman truly truly loves a man she does
not want to sleep with other men at all
it's not this oh you get to do it I want
to do it too because she's so in love
with the man she just wants to be with a
man so
in that in that way I really respect
what you said because it is true in a
lot of women when a man has the balls to
actually tell the truth will in fact
stay because they know they can go get
with the next guy live his shittier life
and then get lied to from a coward I
think it comes from the idea and this
might be controversial but it's the idea
that
you know this is life's not fair this is
how it is men or men I don't know this
is how women are women if you're going
to be men and men and men that's how
they're going to be so if you if you if
you're man enough to say look this is
this is this is the truth this is what
you're gonna have to deal with I love
you but this is what it is I would take
that any day over well the issue is it's
a Marketplace isn't it you know it's
very unromantic and it's very Sansbury
crew to say but the reality is that
dating sex relationships it's a big
Marketplace out there right so the guy
who is high value who has options is
good he's gonna exercise those options
in most cases right now every guy wants
to would like to have multiple women not
every guy is going to be capable of
achieving that so you're going to get
some guys who are sort of lowered down
in the hierarchy right you could date
them or you could marry them and they
would probably be you go to play trans
girl okay one one thing I think people
keep on missing with this is that maybe
you're not really even messing with the
high quality people maybe it's just a
lot of mediocre but good looking people
who have convinced themselves that
they're worthy of the ultimate
commitment and love and attention from
each other when you're you're all as
mediocre as each other right so if
you're dating athletes and rappers who
are known for being promiscuous they're
not particularly men of high stature in
terms of character and you're in a short
skirt an after party you're not
particularly white from your tool right
then so why why do we kind of convince
ourselves that we don't need to
compromise and work for what we want
because I think men understand that you
have to work to get the the woman like
the the one but I never hear women talk
about all the things they need to do to
qualify for the man they actually want
it seems like you don't want to
compromise he must be faithful you must
have this he must have that he must be
loyal or most of the time they say it
when you're not around there most of the
time they can say it when you're when a
man is not around there we don't have to
explicitly state to you what we you know
that's something we do in ourselves and
with our girls and as many of you know I
was just banned on Tic Tac and we are
monetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible